Let's try another example,
follow along with me.
This time we're going to write
a function that takes in a string and
returns a string with
the first letter removed from
the beginning of the string,
and instead placed at the end.
We've got the func let's give it a name.
Let's call it a placeFirstLetterLast.
It's going to take in
a string as a parameter.
Let's call that parameter myString and
it will return a string as well.
And now comes the meat of the function.
Just going to put a placeholder
string here to quiet the compiler.
Let's start out by adding the first
letter to the end of myString.
We can do that using
the append function.
Append is a method, a function
that's part of the String class.
So we call the method append on an
instance of the String class using dot
syntax.
We just type the name of the string,
a dot, and the name of the method
followed by parentheses.
We place any input parameters
between the parentheses.
In this case the parameter is
a character to append to myString.
So how will we get the first
character of myString?
Well, we just wrote a function that
returns the first character of a string.
Let's use that and
put it here is the argument to append.
Hm, okay the compiler's
upset about something.
Let's see what this error says.
Immutable value of type String only
has mutating members named depend.
See, because myString is a parameter,
it defaults to being a constant,
as if it were declared with let.
If we declare it with var,
the error should go away.
Sweet, so far we've appended the first
letter to the end of the string.
Now we need to also remove it
from the beginning of the string.
For that we can use the function,
removeAtIndex.
RemoveAtIndex takes
an index as a parameter.
The index we want to
remove is the startIndex.
And of course instead of returning
placeholder, we want to return myString.
And that ought to do it.
So let's test it out by
calling the function, and
we'll call it on the string Mom.
Over here in the sidebar you can
see that Mom becomes omM, and
we're ready for yoga.
But before we move on, I'd like you to
notice the difference between how we
call global functions,
and how we call methods.
For example, append is called on
an instance of the string class
using dot syntax, it's a method.
Global functions, on the other hand,
like placeFirstLetterLast,
are not called by any
object in particular.